in this video I want to talk about
details of epinephrine signaling cascade
Ruben talked about general scheme so far
we're going to talk now about how
exactly epinephrine the hormone triggers
a response in a Cell so what is
epinephrine epinephrine is also known as
adrenaline and it's typically considered
the fight or flight hormone you may have
heard that sort of phrase before first
thing we have to ask ourselves why I've
been F in red adrenaline is what class
of hormone is this this is an amino acid
derivative specifically epinephrine is a
derivative of tyrosine if you recall
tyrosine structure has the phenyl group
voh on it and this has that portion here
this is the actual structure of
epinephrine now our amino acid
derivatives polar or nonpolar while we
work if you recall they were polar which
means that they'll act via a process in
which they bind a receptor that's on the
cell surface and we'll see that
epinephrine binds via a g-protein
coupled receptor epinephrine is released
from a particular ductless glands called
the adrenal medulla which is actually
right on top of the kidneys and that's
actually the reason it this hormone is
named that epinephrine rotary meets on
top of that the kidney and adrenaline on
top of the kidney an effort and renal
both mean kidney FB and add me on top of
at least in this case so there are some
relevant functions that we want to
consider when we think about epitaphs in
adrenaline or adrenaline rather so the
functions that we're going to be
concerned with is that it acts on liver
cells to increase blood glucose levels
and it does that in two ways that we're
gonna at least talk about so what it can
do is it's going to if it wants to
increase blood glucose that means it
wants to free up glucose
is right so it'll increase glycogen
breakdown and increase gluconeogenesis
in the liver does that make sense well
we want to increase blood glucose right
so we want to free up glucose molecules
well if we're going to be breaking down
glycogen we're taking with taking off
you know glucose at a time when we break
down glycogen so we want to increase
blood glucose levels we're going to
increase the breakdown of glycogen
breakdown the glycogen into into the
glucose molecules and we're also going
to increase gluconeogenesis because
gluconeogenesis of course makes glucose
from pyruvate
now it also acts on muscle cells right
which are cells else well in the body
what does it do there it acts on muscle
cells to make ATP now how will it make
ATP a few ways well it's going to
increase glycogen breakdown actually let
me just keep the sort of same theme by
writing this in green here it'll
increase glycogen breakdown does that
make sense well if we're going to break
down glycogen we're freeing up glucose
okay so so far it doesn't necessarily
make sense but if we take those glucoses
and we have it can go through glycolysis
then we can make ATP so now it makes
sense if we break down glycogen free up
glucose is and allow those glucose is to
go through glycolysis we can make ATP so
it makes sense that we would increase
glycogen breakdown and increase
glycolysis in the muscle cells and we'll
talk more about why that makes sense
just a second I would also increase beta
oxidation what is beta oxidation that's
the process in which we broke down fatty
acids for energy so our muscle cells
would need energy why is this well
recall epinephrine is the fight or
flight hormone so the fight or flight
hormone basically you're going to need
this hormone to go if it's released when
you need to fight or you need to fly so
if you're going to fight or if you're
going to fly away or run away from
danger then your muscles are going to
need energy right they're going to need
energy they're going to make ATP
so um what exactly is going to happen
here the the liver makes glucose right
it increases blood glucose levels and
the muscle breaks glucose down to make
ATP available for fighting or flying
away so your liver it's it's triggered
by epinephrine to make glucose that your
body that your muscles can use and then
once your muscles have that glucose
they're going to go ahead and and break
it down for energy so notice there's a
commonality here between the functions
in both the liver and the muscle cells
we have increased glycogen breakdown or
glycogen degradation so that's something
I made a note here note that it happens
in both organs so how exactly does that
happen
in these how is glycogen breakdown
triggered by epinephrine in a liver or
muscle cell by a g-protein coupled
receptor cascade so if we have a liver
or muscle cell epinephrine is going to
come on over and bind a g-protein
coupled receptor once it binds that it's
going to the g-protein will be activated
now specifically in this case this is a
stimulatory g-protein so some some g
proteins can be inhibitory so stick
stimulatory g proteins are have this
this s has a subscript excuse me sorry
about that so initially when it's
inactive has a gdp-bound once it's
activated it has a GTP bound so the G
the gtp bound alpha subunit of the g
protein will head over to the adenylate
cyclase then add in late cyclase what
does that do it makes cyclic AMP ease
from ATP now we said before that these
cyclic GMP s activate cyclic A&P
dependent protein kinases now in the
case of epinephrine
that protein kinase specifically is
protein kinase a so protein kinase a is
going from a less active state to a more
active state these cyclic AMP ease
causes protein kinase to be active now
this protein kinase is going to go on
ahead and activate instituted since it's
active it's going to go ahead and be a
kinase for proteins it's going to add
phosphate certain proteins now those
proteins are certain enzymes so we're
going to talk about here before I
actually go through and talk about this
I want to refresh your memory about what
these enzymes are so the enzymes are
going to talk about are the target
proteins the target proteins are
glycogen synthase phosphorylase kinase
and glycogen phosphorylase what does
glycogen synthase do well the name kind
of gives it away right it makes glycogen
so bear that in mind
what does phosphorylase kinase do well
it's a kinase so it's going to add a
phosphate group and where it's going
where is going to add that phosphate
group to
phosphorylase what phosphorylase
glycogen phosphorylase which brings me
here glycogen phosphorylase degrades
glycogen so we should keep all these
functions in mind when we're thinking
about this cascade I wanted to refresh
your memory now let's get back to it
so protein kinase a it's active so it's
going to add phosphates it's going to
add a phosphate to glycogen synthase and
turn it into glycogen synthase with a
phosphate group where does it get that
phosphate from while it gets it from ATP
right it's also going to add a phosphate
group to phosphorylase kinase so that
also costs an ATP right the phosphate
gets attached to phosphorylase kinase
now does adding the phosphate to
glycogen synthase make it more or less
active let's think about this for a
second epinephrine right it's supposed
to increase glycogen breakdown so if we
want glycogen be broken down
we want luggage instant days to be
active no we don't want to be making
glycogen we want to be breaking it down
so it's going to be going from a more
active state to a less active state okay
however phosphorylase kinase is what
does that do that's the thing that adds
a phosphate group to to glycogen
phosphorylase in this case it's going
from being less active to more active
now once phosphorylase kinase is active
it's going to add a phosphate group to
glycogen phosphorylase so it's going to
add it from ATP now glycogen
phosphorylase this is the enzyme that
involved involved in breaking down
glycogen do we want this to be active
according to epinephrine yep we want to
increase glycogen breakdown so if we
want to increase packaging breakdown we
want to activate the enzyme that breaks
it down so it's going to go from a less
active state to a more active state so
notice here in this case scroll up a bit
in this case with glycogen synthase
adding the phosphate made it less active
but in the case of phosphorylase kinase
and glycogen phosphorylase adding the
phosphates made them more active so this
is sort of explaining the idea that
adding a phosphate doesn't necessarily
make it enzyme more or less active it
depends on the enzyme itself so now
notice that we have glycogen synthase
less active glycogen phosphorylase more
active like agent synthase the thing
that makes glycogen it's less active so
if the thing that makes glycogen is less
active that means we're going to have
less glycogen made okay in addition
glycogen phosphorylase is more active
this is the thing that breaks down
glycogen so if it's more active that
means more glycogen will be broken down
the overall response is that less
glycogen is made more glycogen is broken
down which is exactly what we want in
the case of Efrain
friend right we want that increased
glycogen breakdown in both the liver and
the muscle cells so does this make sense
I sure hope so the answer is yes why
does it make sense well you don't want
the two opposing processes to be
occurring at the same time right you
don't want to be making glycogen at the
same time as breaking it down you don't
want this enzyme and this enzyme active
at the same time you either want one
active or the other active assuming it's
the same cell and I wrote here isn't it
gnarly how one hormone binding event
caused all of this so just one hormone
right one epinephrine bound here and
then it caused this crazy change so so
what's going on here this is
amplification of this signal that's
called the Cascade effect how is this
signal actually amplified well if we
think about this one epinephrine
molecule bound maybe it created ten
cyclic KMPS each one of those cyclic AMP
es can activate maybe ten protein
kinases so maybe there are a hundred
protein kinases that are active and then
those 100 protein kinases each one can
activate ten have ten events that means
a thousand glycogen synthesis might be
less active and a thousand phosphorylate
kindnesses might be more active so this
is all from initially just one
epinephrine binding so this is the idea
of an application of the signal so how
is this signal actually terminated well
there are three different ways three
ways are you can either blake's
hippocampi down just to a MP and
basically that just makes that that
cyclic portion of the phosphate broken
down so that's catalyzed by cyclic
nucleotide phosphodiester eraser breaks
that up a fun fact there is actually
that this enzyme is inhibited by
caffeine so Kamath caffeine you should
know is a stimulant right so um
if if you if what it does is the way it
works as a stimulant is it inhibits
inhibits the process that stops the
signal right so your body stays wired
bye-bye
epinephrine epinephrine signal is not
terminated if caffeine is around so that
basically allows the stimulatory effects
to continue if cyclic a and P is broken
down then these protein kinases won't be
active anymore
right which would help in terminating
the signal another thing is that the gtp
on the G alpha subunit is hydrolyzed to
a GDP so up here this G alpha subunit
has a gtp so it's active if that gets
hydrolyzed into a GDP then it becomes
inactive right and in tonight's cyclase
wouldn't make any more cyclic AMP ease
so that would aid in terminating the
signal but what if that gtp ACE activity
wasn't there well then that would do
very much the same thing as as this
whole idea of caffeine it would keep
that stimulatory effect going last thing
is protein phosphatases what they redo
is they remove phosphate groups from
target proteins so all these target
proteins that have these phosphate
groups on them they can be taken off and
that would be that would also aid in
terminating the signal I hope that was
all helpful
one last thing I'm a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email at move University
at gmail.com hope that video was helpful
see the description for more details
thanks for watching